we didn't notice how sneaky you were a
Disney Channel sure we saw lots of
obvious references to other Disney
movies in descendant 3 it's pretty easy
when all the characters are the children
of old-school Disney heroes and villains
but you definitely snuck in some Easter
eggs that were way more subtle we're
seriously impressed with the level of
detail you guys used for all the Disney
references there are so many Disney
Easter eggs in descendants three and
they're easy to miss you probably
totally missed a Sleeping Beauty
reference at Jane's party keep watching
to see ten Disney movie Easter eggs in
d3 Audrey's colors we love Audrey's old
look and new look in this movie she
really looks super cool as a villain we
also love Audrey's hair she has pink and
blue hair both before she turns into the
queen of mean and after and you might
have noticed that her whole bedroom is
pink and blue this is a reference to
Sleeping Beauty when the fairies were
fighting over
Aurora's dress the princess ended up in
a half pink have blue ensemble her mom's
two signature colors have rubbed off on
Audrey closed at midnight when we first
see dizzy on the Isle of the Lost she is
outside of her shop she is sweeping just
like Cinderella used to do but there's
another reference about dizzy Stefon
there's a sign that says that the salon
will close at midnight
that's a weird time for a salon to close
but that was just another way for the
show's creators to sneak in an easter
egg midnight is of course when
Cinderella's enchantment ended we love
that subtle reference
bibbidi-bobbidi birthday fairy god
mother says bibbidi bobbidi all the time
it's a reference to her song in
Cinderella
bibbidi bobbidi one two and two can
everybody hear me but did you catch the
reference for Jane's birthday it was
easy to miss the birthday cake that
Carlos made said happy bibbidi-bobbidi
birthday Jane we think that is just the
cutest thing
Carlos is such a great boyfriend too bad
Jane never got to see the awesome cake
the Nuvi case just couldn't resist it
monstros basking buffet there are lots
of little Disney references all over the
Isle of the Lost
but one you probably missed was the name
of a restaurant near dr. Vasily a's
arcade monstros basking
they is a seafood restaurant judging by
the whale on the sign but do you know
what movie it's referencing this Easter
Egg is kicking it old school
monstro is the name of the giant whale
in Pinocchio he's the one who eats
Pinocchio and Jiminy Cricket did you
catch this throwback wrapping paper King
been definitely coordinates his whole
life in yellow and blue these are the
colors of his mom and dad of course the
beasts wore a blue suit and Belle wore a
yellow dress during their first dance
but did you notice what was on Jane's
gift then had wrapped Jane's birthday
present in blue and yellow wrapping
paper and it was printed with the Beast
on it is it weird to have your dad's
cursed face on wrapping paper
we hope he eventually got to give Jane
her gift Soul Stealer we absolutely
loved Hades as mouths dad we also loved
the rock and roll vibe he had going on
it was totally fitting for the god of
the underworld when he was still in
charge of the underworld he would
oversee all the souls that pass he also
had a habit of stealing Souls like he
did to Megara in Hercules in descendents
3 the back of his leather jacket said
Soul Stealer it's both scary and a
direct reference to his original role
V's heart Eevee is definitely not her
mother's Goddard's the Evil Queen is
well evil and Eevee is basically the
sweetest person ever but that doesn't
mean she doesn't embrace her roots her
pin cushion is shaped like a heart and
it is constantly being stabbed with pins
this is a Snow White Easter Egg your
mother ordered the Huntsman to carve out
Snow White's heart ring
[Music]
but thankfully he didn't this is a
pretty dark reminder of what Evie's mom
is capable of seeing for me site Falls
was one of the best songs in descendents
3 this fight scene between the BK's and
the enchanted Knights is epic we loved
that mal cast a spell and made them
dance when uma got up to dance she
started singing a familiar tune it is
the same tune that Ariel saying to give
Ursula her voice and Little Mermaid it's
only fitting that uma saying this since
she's Ursula's daughter
we've got Ursula hum did a lot when Emma
was growing up
Korona seal there's another really
subtle easter egg during the nightfall
scene the Sun on the stained-glass
window is the symbol of the kingdom of
Corona
that's where Rapunzel is from it's
totally random since there are no
descendants of Rapunzel or Mother Gothel
in the movies can you imagine what a BK
that was descended from Gothel would be
like forgotten invitation
now's mom is the one who cast the spell
on Audrey's mom it's only fitting that
Audrey used Maleficent scepter for all
her evil deeds but there was one line
that was almost a direct quote from
Maleficent such someone forgot to invite
me well if it's it not getting invited
to Aurora's christening was why she
cursed her in the first place we love
how Audrey snuck in this subtle Easter
egg which of these Easter eggs did you
miss did you notice any others let us
know in the comments thanks for watching
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to the things for more great
content we'll catch you next time
[Music]